optimal minim at this altitude I can run
flat out for a half mile before my hands
start shaking can I ask you a personal
question now broke what if the I'm a
cybernetic organism living dissue over
metal
[Music]
endoskeleton this episode is brought to
you by fresh books fresh books is used
by a ton of the startups that I work
with or advise many the fastest growing
it is used by almost all of the
contractors that I work with it is the
easiest way online to send invoices get
paid track your time for invoicing track
your clients so they get to the point of
paying you all that stuff that you could
possibly find and right now you can get
a free month of complete unrestricted
use and you do not need a credit card
for the trial to claim your free month
just go to freshbooks.com
Tim and enter Tim in the how did You
Hear About Us section you can of course
customize it to fit your brand with your
own logo and color and freshbooks shows
you whether or not for instance a client
has looked at the invoice they can send
late payment reminders to your clients
automatically so you do not have to
think about it or chase them down and
you can track your hours you can do all
sorts of things there are mobile applets
you take pictures of your receipts and
freshbooks or organize them for you
later it is a great piece of software
and if you are in a small business or
maybe a fast growing business that is
feeling growing pains and you need to
streamline then
this is a place to look because
certainly for me this has been a
headache in the past and it doesn't have
to be a headache for you so check out
freshbooks.com
and try it out and see what you
think this episode is brought to you by
99 designs 99 designs is a great partner
for creating and growing your business
it's a One-Stop shop for all of your
graphic design needs whether that's a
logo website business card or anything
else I use 99 designs to get book cover
prototypes for the 4-Hour Body which
went on to become a number one New York
Times bestseller I also use them for
banner ads illustrations and other
things with 99 designs designers around
the world compete to create the best
design for you you give feedback and
then pick your favorite you end up happy
or you get your money back it's very
simple you can check out a few of my own
designs and those of yours meaning Tim
Ferris show listeners at 99designs.com
and right now my listeners you guys will
get a free $99 upgrade on your first
design that's 99designs.com
check it
out hello ladies and gents this is Tim
Ferris and welcome to another episode of
the Tim Ferris show where it is my job
to deconstruct worldclass performers
whether they are chess prodigies hedge
fund managers
actors military
strategists athletes really anything and
everything because you find a lot of
commonalities across these areas of
expertise
this is an unusual episode and I'm going
to start with a question why did Ben
Franklin complain that settlers along
the frontier were constantly absconding
to live with the American Indian tribes
but that the opposite never happened
this episode we're going to talk about
human nature quite a lot and look at
evolutionary biology if you want a
better understanding of Warriors tribal
societies human nature including the
pieces that we might dislike or deny and
what we can learn from it all then this
episode is for you my guest is Sebastian
younger an incredible writer number one
New York Times best-selling author of
The Perfect Storm fire a death in
Belmont war and his latest book tribe
which I read in about a day and a half
just ingested it rapid fire as an
award-winning journalist a contributor
to Vanity Fair contributing editor that
is and a special correspondent at ABC
News he has covered major international
news stories around the world has
received both a national magazine award
and a peab body award and he's also a
documentary filmmaker whose debut film
rrio a featurelength doc co-directed
with Tim hether inton which was
nominated for an Academy Award and won
the grand jury prize at Sundance
Restrepo for those who haven't seen it
Chronicles the deployment of a platoon
of US soldiers in Afghanistan's Coral
Valley and it is widely considered to
have broken new ground in war reporting
it is very rugged and raw younger has
since produced and directed three
additional docs about war and its
aftermath in our conversation which took
place at my house we cover rights of
Passage and their importance his entire
career Warfare the art of great
non-fiction writing and storytelling
journ investigative or rather
participatory journalism PTSD and much
much more please be forewarned that some
of these topics will no doubt offend
many of you and this is a good thing and
I'm going to paraphrase here but I
believe it was May West who said those
who are offended easily should be
offended more often and I urge you to
bite your lip if need be step outside
your comfort zone and listen to the
entire episode there are many gems
within including
all sorts of hilarious stories
surprising statistics and also some
tear-jerking epiphanies and tales that
Sebastian has to share he's lived an
incredible life a very tough and rugged
life uh certainly in his deployments or
rather assignments that were in war torn
countries and there's a lot to be
learned here so please be patient please
listen to this conversation with
Sebastian
younger Sebastian welcome to the show
thank you very much it's nice to be here
it's so exciting to finally get a chance
to hang because we have a mutual friend
and Josh wein who's been on the podcast
twice for those who don't know uh the
basis for searching for Bobby fiser but
the book and the movie but a lot more
than that I mean a real masterful and
kind soul Who's uh who's who's really
taught me a lot but the the first
encounter we had was at Josh's wedding
and I guess we were piecing it together
and that was probably like 10 years ago
something something along those lines
and this is the first chance that we've
had to really kind of dig in and get to
know each other let's start with some
mundane stuff but you have a book here
on your backpack could you tell us what
you're reading at the moment I'm reading
the biography of uh Thomas Payne one of
the um intellectual fathers of American
independence from Britain in the
1770s and did somehow when uh this is
this is maybe TMI for people listening
but uh Sebastian arrived before I got
back to my place and I I was doing some
Acro yoga long story and then you had
picked up the letters from A stoic and
did the stoics come up in the book about
pain yeah uh the stoics the Greek stoics
were greatly admired by pain I didn't
know much about them I knew the I knew
the word uh and I and I'd heard of
senica but I'm I'm incredibly um I'm
sort of half illiterate right and or
untutored and and what the book said
about the stoics was amazing and and you
know I'm not religious I didn't grow up
going to church I don't believe in God
and so if you're like me you're always
looking
for um a way to sort of order the
universe that's um inspiring or
reassuring and sort of makes sense of
things and so what they said about the
stoics I really really identified with
I'm like oh I got to learn more about
the stoics and then here I was before I
took a nap on your couch I I sort of
pawed through your book collection over
there and there was uh there was the
letters of Sonica and I grabbed it and
sat down and I almost started whooping I
mean with with with pleasure I mean I
that the things that he was writing
2,000 years ago were so modern so
amazing so essential and I you know I I
just thought I get have to get this book
immediately so you you seem to be a uh a
a stoic without calling yourself such uh
in in a lot of respects but I want to
bring up something that I know nothing
about but a fan had asked me to inquire
about which is chainsaw ask him about
the chainsaw so let's let's talk about
your career with chainsaws could you
give us some Contex yeah absolutely so I
studied anthropology in college because
it interested me and that um that was on
the East Coast yeah at Wesley University
in Connecticut and uh I know interested
in being an anthropologist but it
actually helped me throughout my career
as a writer after I got out of college I
sort of Walled around you know I waited
tables I did various things to earn
money while I was trying to become a
writer and um I was very slowly getting
into journalism but it didn't pay very
well and I got a job eventually as a
climber for tree companies and I would
work 890 ft in the air with a chainsaw
on a rope taking trees down in pieces uh
you know RI RI you know rigging rigging
branches and lowering them as I cut them
and taking off the tops of trees and
taking them down all the way to the
ground it was extremely dangerous work
or I should say it's dangerous if you
make a mistake there isn't any random
danger in the top of a tree and I
realized at one point if I get killed
doing this and plenty of people do if I
get killed doing this it will be because
I killed myself by accident no one it's
not a random um it's not a situation
where something random will kill me that
was very reassuring and it also trained
me to really focus on being in the
present moment well at one point I
wasn't in the present moment and the
chainsaw hit the back of my leg and to
tore open the back of my leg and I you
know I had been a marathon runner and
stuff and I was super wor worried about
my achilles tendon so it hit your lower
leg or your entire back of your leg hit
it it it I managed to drag it across the
back of my ankle right where the
Achilles is and uh I turned the chainsaw
and I was way up in a tree you know on a
on a rope and I chain I turned the
chainsaw off and I clipped it to my belt
and uh and looked down and and I pulled
my leg I pulled the wound open cuz I
wanted you know you go into shock and
you get very um clinical immediately
right and I pulled the wound open and I
wanted to see if the the Achilles was
intact indeed it was by the way an
Achilles is about the thickness of a
number two pencil and it's white just in
case you ever wanted to know what your
Achilles looks like and um I was so
relieved to see it intact but I was
still pretty messed had a pretty messed
up leg and I repelled down to the ground
and my crew took me to the hospital and
um as I was recovering I had this
thought um that people die all the time
doing dangerous jobs in this country um
they're mostly workingclass
working-class men um and they do they
work in industries that are very
dangerous drilling for oil logging
commercial fishing that the nation needs
done and um they die in numbers
comparable to soldiers in war actually
but they don't get acknowledged they
don't get honored and I thought maybe
I'll write about dangerous jobs and that
set me on course to write my first book
called The Perfect Storm about a um a
huge storm that among other things sank
a commercial fishing boat at se so there
you know we I was lamenting the fact
it's not really the right way to put it
uh I was saying that we could probably
talk for seven hours there's so many
things I want to ask you about and so
many things that Josh wanted me to ask
you also but let's let's go back to the
you repelling down trees for a second
how did you get that job I mean what
qualified you or did not qualify you how
did that come to pass like all well like
many good stories it started in a bar I
was I was
broke uh I was broke and I was at a bar
one evening and I was sitting next to
this guy and we just started talking and
he said he owned a tree company and he
said he was looking for a climber and
you know I was a pretty athletic kid and
um and he said listen I'll train you to
climb if you'll work for me but I can't
give you full-time work only occasional
work that's all I got and um I was like
yeah absolutely so I start he sort of
trained me how to climb and I the great
thing about climbing was that I could
make I mean for an unemployed freelance
writer in the in the late
80s I could make a couple hundred a day
cash I could make 500 bucks a day even
$1,000 a day depending on the job and so
it and I could so I could work one day a
week and sort of live off it it was the
perfect job for someone who was
trying to do something else and needed
some
time the athleticism we were talking
about this when we were having lunch
together what was your what did your
running times look like when you were at
your Peak my running times were almost
fast enough what they look like from my
perspective what was your what was your
mile I ran 412 for the mile that's a
fast mile I mean from my
perspective that that that seems
extremely fast and then you got into
marathons after that yeah I ran uh sure
a 904 for the 2 Mile 245 for 5 miles and
a 221 Marathon those are my sort of the
set of distance records that I had so
the the The Perfect Storm uh I heard you
described or I read you being described
as uh based on that work and I'm
paraphrasing here but the next Hemingway
along those lines and Josh had also
observed I think the way he put it was
and to quote the the one of the leanest
writers I know so little
between the
muscle how did you develop your writing
style and if that's a bad question feel
free to rephrase it but how how did you
develop that leanness at that point in
your
life well you know I I never studied
English and I never studied writing um
in college or um or after um but I read
a lot I grew up in a household with a
lot of books my father was educated in
Europe he grew up in Europe and um
reading was this um sort of imperative I
mean I mean it was you just you don't
not read you know and I read John MC
Joan didan uh Peter mat Ernest Hemingway
of course a little bit of
funner um I mean I could go on but I but
I I gravitated
towards language sort that was efficient
and lean and Innovative
and when I would read a book that I
liked I would think about um like John
MC I would think about why is it I like
it what is it about the writing that
that appeals to me and when I and even
more importantly when I read books I
didn't like I tried to figure out what
was it about that sentence about that
paragraph that that repels me and um
that was how I learn to write and and
and it's a sort of process of natural
selection I just kept reading
things that reinforced the style that I
was drawn to anyway and I kept writing
more and more in that style and I think
if you know those writers and you read
me you can see my ancest my literary
ancestry pretty clearly what Drew you to
writing so you weren't taking classes
explicitly focused on turning you into a
journalist it doesn't sound like or a
writer so what Drew you to writing I
well
I it happened quite suddenly I uh I I
was a good distance runner in college
and I had to write a thesis and I'd
heard that the
Navajo had this very strong tradition
ancient tradition of of running and they
were still they were sort of still at it
in in a kind of traditional way and they
were amazing s of track and cross
country
athletes and they would had Blended the
two uh the two disciplines and so I I
did my field workor on the Navajo
reservation I spent a summer there I
trained with their best Runners you know
is up at 6 7,000 feet I live in Fort
Defiance um Arizona and I wrote a thesis
about Navajo long-distance running that
was the name of the thesis and uh
apparently thesis titles are supposed to
have a colon in them and I didn't know
that I just called it Navajo
longdistance running and uh and I
I I just came alive academically doing
that I mean I was a pretty indifferent
student I was much more of an athlete
than a student and um I just came alive
and the idea that you could go out into
the world and gather information gather
research interview people and bring it
back and then turn it into words that
people will read and be moved by
informed by and moved by and maybe
Changed by that to me was just such an
extraordinary idea and so I thought
maybe what I'll maybe I'll be a
journalist it sounds like journalism
maybe I'll try to be a journalist and I
literally
graduated with you know my graduation
plan postgraduation plan was maybe I'll
try to be a journalist like that was
literally the plan I had in my head
seems to worked out well eventually I
mean eventually in between I was a
pretty bad waiter in Washington DC and
in Cambridge and you know like I I mean
I it took a while I mean it what my
first book came out when I was 35 and I
I had virtually no income from writing
before that no so the the first book was
the perfect storm or no yes that's right
yes it was so was that your first aside
from the thesis long form piece of
writing I mean it's just that that's
incredible that I wrote yeah and I wrote
some article you know I you know I wrote
some articles for the Boston Phoenix and
then I got into a couple magazines but
it was not I couldn't even come close to
stitching together an income I could
live on did you sell the book before you
wrote it or write it before you sold it
um I worked on the story for about a
year and uh just sort of on my own dime
and uh and then and I wrote I wrote a
magazine piece that outside magazine
took and then
I got a a book contract from ww Norton a
very very modest book contract but it
got you know it got me going based on
the magazine piece yeah and and I you
know I ginned up some outline that you
know sort of showed what how I was going
to expand the story and you already had
quite a bit in your back pocket then at
that point yeah I already had a bill
Craig full of notes and you know
whatever I mean I already done you know
years worth the work on this but I was
used to I was used to I mean everything
I'd ever written I'd written um on my
own time and then tried to sell it right
I was constantly sort of pedaling
finished pieces of writing right I yeah
I never got an assignment the first
assignment I did I mean the first story
that I placed in the Boston Phoenix
which when I was 23 was like a big deal
um was about tugboats in Boston Harbor
and they didn't commission that why
would they right but I just I I moved to
Boston and I just thought what's the
coolest thing in Boston maybe it's
tugboats you know like I so I just
started hanging out on tugboats and I
sent them a pretty nice piece of writing
and and it was my first published piece
up there and it was called Towing the
line and uh and that was my sort of
entry into
journalism what was your writing process
like after the magazine piece comes out
you get the book contract did you
continue taking other jobs or did you
buckle down to focus full-time on the
writing oh I did tree workk throughout I
mean I you know I didn't my Advance was
pretty small and and um I mean and as
was a appropriate I mean I was a totally
unknown writer and it was it was a
totally bizarre Topic at the time right
so I I'm not complaining but the advance
was quite small so I did tree work
throughout the you know a couple of days
a week I'd be up in the trees but I also
after I after I finished my book
proposal by some miracle I had an agent
by the way I hadn't made a dime for him
for 10 years right but he liked my
writing right God bless him how did he
get in touch with met I met him his name
is Stuart kvy and we're he's still my
agent we're really good friends and he
said it was the way he met me was sort
of the ultimate sort of Agents nightmare
his um a client of his who wrote
academic papers in other words not a big
pay gig but he sort of handled he
handled the academic career of this guy
who was a Shakespeare scholar okay it
took him three hours a year you know
whatever that guy's college roommate was
my
father and he got the message that his
arguably smallest client's College
roommate's son wanted to be a writer and
would he read some stuff and Stuart was
like that's about as bad as it get like
that that is about as unpromising As It
Gets In the agent world but he's a great
you know Steward's a great guy and he
has an open mind and he read some stuff
that I'd written and really liked it it
took another 10 years for him to make
any money off me but it's you know like
he he saw something long-term investment
it was he saw something there and and
I'm eternally grateful to him but I so I
gave him my book proposal based on the
article and then I went off to Bosnia I
wanted to be a war reporter and um in
case the author thing didn't work out
and there was no reason to think it was
going to work out and I didn't want to
do tree workk my whole life so I went
off there was a Civil War in Bosnia and
I went off to learn how to be a war
reporter and I was there I you know I
finally came home in '94 um because
Stuart sent me a fact saying I I managed
to sell your book you got to come home
and I came home what uh in during the
period that you were up in the trees a
few days a
week what did your uh or once you'd sold
the book I'm not I'm mixing up my
chronology just a little bit but what
did your writing
process your daily or weekly schedule
look like at that point how do you write
I know it's a very boring maybe uh often
asked question but I'm fascinated by
this and Josh wanted me to dig into it
so
it's well you know really there's two
kinds of writing there's fiction and
there's non-fiction and the first step
if you're a journalist which I consider
all non-fiction should be journalism is
should be considered journalism there
aren't other rules for literary
non-fiction or anything it's all
journalism as far as I'm concerned if
you're a journalist the first thing you
have to do is do your research right
because you need something you're you're
you're writing about the real world and
you need facts and quotes and interviews
and all that so my writing process
really starts out in the world
as I'm researching a story or in a
library or on the Internet or whatever
as I'm researching a story fiction
writers they depend on some this weird
sort of pipeline to God right I mean
they're trying to they're trying to
reimagine the world in a way that's
never been done before and reproduce it
on the page and have people enter this
fictional world and be riveted by it and
that's that's where inspiration comes in
and that's where you have to really be
at your desk every morning CU you never
know when God's going to going to talk
to you and I mean God figuratively I
don't believe in God but the creative
gods and and um but for a journalist
it's much more like carpentry you you
get the lumber you get the bricks you
you build the basement you start putting
it together I mean there's a process and
there's a lot of inspiration in the
actual language that you use but it's
much more procedural than I think
fiction writing probably
is the uh you mentioned MC so the the
only or the most impactful writing class
I ever took was with MC it was a small
seminar of about 12 to 15 students at
Princeton and
um so you'll appreciate this just as a
side note so we spent so I still have to
this day downstairs an entire three-
ring binder full of all of my notes from
that class and I would say three4 of
them are all about structure and how he
thinks about structure which is
extremely visual in a lot of cases and
he would map out just like an architect
with a blueprint the structure of his
piece based B on what he had gathered
and all of these elaborate forms and
some would be like a seesaw others would
be a circle others would be in some kind
of weird like cylindrical abstract piece
of art but there's a visual
representation of how he saw the story
in its visual structure and or visual
representation
but uh and and this is going to segue
somewhere but I remember we had to apply
to get into the class and I I I don't
think and I still don't think I'm a
particularly good writer they're a much
better writer there uh
but we had to do short assignments every
week and they would be on the most the
most boring topics possible deliberately
to try to make us Force us to make them
interesting and when we got our first
assignments back the routine was we'd
have one group seminar a week and then
we each got to spend I think an hour
one-on-one with him going over our
writing assignments throughout the week
and he handed our our our assignments
back and he goes now be as I'm handing
these out I want you guys to remember
you're all good writers so don't get
demoralized and there was more red ink
than Black Ink on the page I mean he
just eviscerated everyone and not in a
malicious way but he took out all of the
bloat all of the redundancy all of the
ambiguity and um for those people
interested he he there are a number of
interviews he did for I think the Paris
review on the art of non-fiction which
are just fantastic uh but what I wanted
to ask you was uh and and then we're
going to we're certainly going to spend
a lot of time talking about your
experiences in war and with Warriors and
Veterans of different
types who were some of the most uh
influential mentors or influences you
had say before the age of
30 well let me just say MC um I mean
you're very lucky to have taken a class
with him he he was a mentor that I
didn't personally know for me through
his Works he was and um it's very
interesting to hear what you said about
him mapping out structure because I
think I think good structure is an
extremely visual thing I think when
people who are good at structure I'd
like to think I am he definitely is I
think they arrive at the structure with
the visual part of their brain I mean I
think youve probably mapped his brain
while it was at work you would see that
part light up and that's just what I'm
guessing when I write out structure it
looks more like a a a diagram to a
circuit board or something it's not I
don't it's not quite architect like
geometric shapes but it's it's very
um
uh it's very visual it represented
completely visually and I feel it like
when I get the right shape to something
I feel it it's a it's a very interesting
process that for me is is um it feels
it's it's something that feels like the
Divine Spark that is finally sort of
like blessed me with its presence so
let's say you have your your box full of
notes right so you've you've dug into a
given topic you've gone out in the field
uh and we could use the perfect storm
for this example because perhaps it's
evolved or changed over
time what then like do you sit down and
go through and highlight certain pieces
and
then number them and order them in some
fashion what's what's the process of
turning that
heap of information into something that
might become a book um I read through
all my interviews with a red magic
marker marker and I Redline the stuff
the good
quotes and I read through all of the
research material and I keep and I
underline the stuff that's interesting
to me and then I go through everything
I've underlined and I just write lists
of what I consider the assets that I
have to work with um
and once once I have those lists they
cover many pieces of paper then I'll
start to Clump them into sort of General
topics you know history of fishing in
New England and the physics of wave
motion I'm I'm referencing topics in the
perfect store um night life in
Gloucester you know whatever and uh and
then once I have those big chunks I
start to and this is where the visual
visualness comes in visuality comes in I
start to try a picture how could I
arrange those in a way where the energy
and the interest in the
reader GA gathers and builds and then
achieves some sort of catharsis towards
the end and it's a very intuitive
process but I got to say I could never
do it without writing it down I mean I
mean it it it's a I'm I'm literally
moving ideas around on a piece of paper
until they look right and and that's the
part of writing that to me is almost
closer to Art than a a sort of
intellectual Pursuit I uh so I used to
do this physically and then I ended up
using a piece of software called scrier
which is originally for playwrights that
allows you to move pieces around like
this and so I've done my last three
books using this software called scrier
which allows me to move these pieces
around without separate files for each
document so I can actually see sort of
the table of contents as I rearrange it
I can resection things it's uh proven
really helpful for me
uh now MC just to talk about daily
routine so he is one of those guys in
the non-fiction world I can't do this
cuz I want to slam my head in a carard
door if I try this for one day or like
jump out a window he literally sits down
like eight once he has his
information 8:00 a.m. to 6:00 p.m. come
H high water he's like staring at the
blank page with a break for lunch and
swimming as I remember it and it just
drove me to Madness to do that it was so
depressing so I tend to do
my best writing and I wish this were
different honestly but my best synthesis
I can do interviews research all that
throughout the day but in terms of
piecing it together into some type of
narrative it's like 10 or 11:00 p.m. to
like 5:00 a.m. that's just my window for
whatever reason do you do you write
throughout the day do you tend to do
your best writing in the mornings at
night what does that look like I I do my
best writing when something's
newe spoken as a real journalist who's
actually worked for papers and whatnot
yeah and that feeling of urgency might
come 6 months out if it's a book
deadline or it might be the next morning
if it's you're trying to finish finish
up a magazine piece but that intensity
you know it's like athletes you know I
mean you know athletes in the big game
or the big race or whatever I mean that
that intensity can bring out something
that you didn't even know you had access
to much less embodied right and um so
the time of day you know I you know I I
have a cup of coffee and I sit down I
write for a couple hours to I get bored
if I feel that I'm blocked in my writing
usually with that blocked meaning I I
just can't write the next section I keep
rewriting and it doesn't work and it's
stuck it it's not that I'm blocked it's
that I don't have that I don't have
enough research to write with power and
knowledge about that topic it always
means it's not that I can't find the
right words it's that I don't have the
ammunition right the words aren't there
in the first place yeah cuz I don't have
the ammo I don't have the goods I have
not gone out into the world and brought
back the goods that I'm writing about
and you never want to solve a research
problem with language you never want to
like be such a fine writer that you can
sort of thread the needle and get
through a thin patch in your research
just cuz you're such a great Pros artist
use some linguistic smok and mirrors
gloss over the fact that you don't have
the research yeah it's just and
and and and you know literary writers
and I like to think of myself as a
literary writer I think sometimes think
that language is so magical and so
powerful that you should be able to sort
of do almost anything with it and and
and and this actually it's not true and
it shouldn't be true mhm what do you
think is the if you were
say giving a this would be an odd place
to give a commencement speech but uh
commencement speech at to graduating
seniors in high school I've done that oh
you have great perfect well then let me
not ask the question I was going to ask
what did you talk about
I was speaking at a at a very um very
kind of elite um uh school private
school in New York City and uh these
kids were going off either to college or
to or to high school I can't remember
anyway these are very very privileged
very smart very educated
children and um the exceedingly
accomplished parents right and um I said
to them something
like the most the hardest thing you're
ever the hardest thing you're ever going
to do I I was like you're programmed to
succeed you guys are programmed to
succeed the hardest thing you're ever
going to do in your life is fail at
something and if you don't start failing
at things you will not live a full life
you'll you'll be living a cautious life
on a path that you know is pretty much
guaranteed to more or less
work that's not getting the most out of
this amazing world we live in and you
have to you have to do the hardest thing
that you've not been prepared for in
this school or any school you have to
you have to be prepared to fail and and
that's how you're going to expand
yourself and grow and then you'll
really as you work through that process
of failure and learning then you will
really deepen into the human being
you're capable of being and um M four
years ago who knows how it's going for
them well the uh we were we were stting
about this before we started recording a
little bit which is uh you how I was
commenting on how accidental my career
and i' kind of put that in air quotes is
I mean it I couldn't have possibly
planned this path uh and you echoed
something to similar effect and uh on
the on the on the failure point I mean
we were talking since since you're uh
now training in boxing uh it made me
think of I think it's custom who is the
most formative trainer of Mike Tyson who
said you know everybody as a plan until
they get punched in the face so uh along
those lines the question I was going to
ask uh it was specific to journalism so
if people came to you these kids
graduating seniors and they said I want
to be a journalist it's it's a 20 of
these kids and they're about to go off
to college what should I study what
should I do what should I avoid what
would your advice be to
them I mean the path that I took is the
one I know best obviously and I would
say what worked for me I mean as a
journalist I'm very hesitant to actually
give advice to people like I feel that's
like one of the not like in my book
tribe I really I I really try not to
tell the country what I think we all
should do um I might try to pry bar that
out of you but well I you know I I I
think it's there are ways there's
there's other language you can use where
you're not issuing a directive but
you're saying you're giving some wisdom
so what I so what I would say to a
someone like that is what worked for me
was to read an enormous amount
to think about what I read and why I
liked it or didn't like it anthropology
is an amazing discipline that gives you
tools to understand almost every
cultural social
situation um in the world and um and you
but mostly you must have an enormous
Appetite For Humanity and for life and
for the world I mean you really have to
feel like you cannot fill yourself up
enough with this amazing place that we
live in
like if you have that feeling and
sincerely have it um you'll do okay if
not at writing at
something and that that hunger for
Humanity that interest in humanity is
that what drove you to want to go into a
war torn country or territory and
observe and write and capture or was it
something else like why did that a few
come about specifically there's a few
things you know I grew up in a in a
pretty affluent suburb of Boston I grew
up in a very physically protected way um
I got to 18 I felt like I'd never
been um I'd never really been challenged
I'd never been faced with a situation
that I didn't know I could
survive and having studied a lot of
anthropology you know through college as
I moved through my 20s I thought this is
ridiculous I'm not an adult yet I'm not
a man yet I mean you you you cross that
threshold into adulthood into man Hood
by facing something that could destroy
you and and initiation rights around in
tribal societies around the
world um their main purpose is to
confront young men and women young women
have a different challenge that they
have to face is equally equally daunting
but young men face this challenge of in
these initiation rights of sort of
demonstrating that they will face the
most painful scariest thing things
possible for their Community for their
people um and that's adulthood and
that's manhood and you know I'd hit 30
and other than a you know a chainsaw
injury here or there I hadn't really
been tested in a real way and my father
grew up in Europe during World War II
and war is this sort of
archetypal um ordeal it's a sort of
ancient in some ways an ancient thing
and it's a very very um you a lot of
societies it is the gate for better or
worse I mean I know there's a political
conversation here that we can have but
for better or worse it's many societies
sort of see it as the gateway to
adulthood to man to manhood specifically
for men and I went off to Bosnia um
partly because I wanted to become a war
reporter and I was you know sort of at a
loss as to how to make a living and you
know live an adult life and partly
because I felt like I was still a child
and that war would transform me in some
ways that nothing else could
so I want to this is this is uh jumping
around uh of course but there are a
couple of stories that I'd love to talk
about that are in the book I'm holding
in my hand which is tribe uh subtitle on
homecoming and belonging so I get sent a
lot of books and I very rarely read them
uh this one uh of course because of the
the background that the shared
friendship that we have with Josh and my
familiar with your work made me more
inclined to read it I read this in a day
and a half and for those who have seen
my examples of my note taking I just
have an index of notes that spans all of
the front matter of the book basically
uh there are some fantastic stories in
this book and I I had Fallout questions
even if we weren't recording this like
over a bottle of wine that I wanted to
ask you
so can you please explain what Skin
Walkers are you mentioned the Navajo
earlier and why they're in this book
because I wanted to hear more about this
yeah so Skin
Walkers were this thing that I never
heard of that I first encountered when
when I was on the Navajo reservation in
1983 as a 19-year-old 20-year- old
whatever I was and um basically the
Navajo believed in something that other
cultures would call werewolves these
were nav the belief was that there were
certain Navajo mostly men who had
basically turned right they'd lost their
their humanity and they'd become animals
but animals are a source of power in a
lot of native societies um they became
animals in the sense that they had no um
human
affiliation and they did this by putting
on the the the hide of a wolf and that
gave them the powers of a wolf the
powers of being able to run very very
fast for a long distance um the powers
of being invisible of being very very
ferocious when need be incredible
hunters and that these skin they were
called Skin Walkers and that these Skin
Walkers um were they were basically
adopting the skills and powers of a
warrior except they were using it
against their own people and that they
would kill their fellow Navajo and eat
them in the middle of the night and the
Navajo in 1983 on the reservation where
I lived were absolutely terrified of
this phenomenon as terrified as they I'm
sure they were 100 years prior and I got
to say the desert out there is a big
lonely place
and I started to feel their Terror I
mean I start I mean I you know I didn't
literally believe that these things
exist but the belief system that was
around me still made me deeply deeply
scared of them it was extraordinary
experience for a rationalist like myself
my father's a physicist I don't believe
in God he didn't believe in anything but
what he could measure and and observe
and all of a sudden there I was in my
trailer you know very very scared at at
certain moments of these things and of
these Skin Walkers and so I as I as I
wrote about it in my thesis I said you
know the Skin Walkers are basically the
the the universal human fear that you
can defend yourself as a society as a
community you can defend yourself
against all outside
enemies but you're completely vulnerable
to one madman in your midst you know one
psychopath one sociopath paath basically
that has no no feeling of protectiveness
of humanity towards his
neighbors uh can kill more people than
the enemy can and that made me think of
the awful Spate of um mass shootings in
this country that have suddenly become
so commonplace in the last 10 or 15
years and and and it gave me the idea
that the mass Shooters in Aurora
Colorado and at Sandy Hook and we all
know the the names
um that they are our society's version
of the
skinwalkers so the part of what I enjoy
about your writing and uh specifically
in this book is
your
Frank writing about Concepts that we
tend to very cleanly separate in a
binary way uh
so uh and it's really I think a
discussion uh that I hunger for that is
I feel hard to
have in many different uh sort of Mo
modern I'm struggling for language here
because it's it's a feeling that I get
that I get very frustrated by and that
is like a discussion of manhood and
rights of Passage and the clear
historical importance of some of these
uh bonds forged in extreme circumstances
between men that in the safety of these
sort of cocoons that we have in various
cities or
elsewhere do not exist but problems
manifest nonetheless or perhaps to an
even greater extent and in current
climate of a lot of political
correctness that's sort of uh for boten
like a lot of these topics just don't
get broached uh but the I'd love for you
to talk a little bit about your
experience with uh I think this was in
Spain with the Viking
helmet
um because I think it it illustrates a
very important Point uh if if you
remember the story uh I'd love for you
to describe what happened exactly with
this Viking helmet yeah I I mean I and I
think our society which really I feel
really does strive I mean just to
address your earlier point about
political correctness I think we really
are in a very um righteous way striving
for fairness and equality throughout our
society I think we really
are and it makes it but we're also the
product of our biology and our
Evolution
and the two are not easy Partners right
I mean throughout the mamalian world
males and females are built differently
and do different things and are good at
different things that's just an a fact
of
nature
if we want the Sexes to be equal in our
society those inherent differences
become potentially problematic and as a
result instead of trying to figure out
how to reconcile those very real
differences in an equitable system
people and well-meaning people that some
of them are good friends of mine would
just rather you not acknowledge the
differences and that there's a
short-term logic to that but there's a
long-term loss you know and eventually
no we we won't have really equality in
the society uh until those unnegotiable
differences are actually incorporated
into our equality um and um at anyway
that's my you know what you brought up
about sort of PC thinking it's it can be
very infuriating but it's a funny thing
it's
infuriating even though it's trying to
do the right thing but it's still
infuriating and I'm going to I'm going
to hit pause on the Viking helmet which
we going to get to uh but there's
another I have so many notes in this
book it's just unbelievable uh the
let's because you you brought up these
uh what most people would would consider
gender-based differences uh could you
talk for a second and this is something
I'd never really considered but gender
role switching uh if this makes any
sense and uh this was even in same-sex
groups uh this was this was very I I
found this very thought-provoking but if
if you could perhaps describe what I'm
very clumsily trying to allude to that
would be yeah well one of the things
that's interesting is that if you if you
take passers by in a moment of Crisis I
mean every everyone will jump into a a
burning building to save their child
maybe to save their spouse possibly
their their parents-in-law you know but
whatever you have sort of familiar
relations and people will risk their
lives to to help the people that they
love and it makes sense right but if you
look at
situations in public in this anonymous
society that we have and someone's in
danger who goes to their aid right that
happens all the time in New York someone
falls under the subway tracks and the
train is coming who jumps down onto the
tracks to help
them almost invariably it's a man now I
feel like I'm very sexist in saying that
but statistics aren't sexist and they've
done studies of this
and men are um for a number of physical
and ological reasons very very prone
towards that kind of impulsive
risk-taking that sort of in the on the
spot in the moment decision to jump onto
some railroad tracks while a train's
coming it's not that they're
braver it's that they have psychological
and physical predispositions and
capacities that allow them in fact
promote them to do that so if you look
at these
stories in something like 95% of
bystander rescues are performed by men
okay so when you have a society that's
encountering a difficulty and that can
either be be the Blitz in London which I
write about or that could be a um a
group of coal miners who were trapped in
a coal mine disaster in the 1950s in
Canada you need people who are in the
quote male role of rescuing and
risk-taking but then this other thing is
important and it's a and it's a kind of
moral
courage and it does not require
spontaneous muscular action um with
disre complete disregard for your own
life right that's not what's required as
important as that is there's something
else moral C courage where you you
basically are like providing the sort of
moral fiber for the group and you you
act as a kind of conscience for the
group and women are very very good at
that and they did a study of during
World War II of who helped hide Jewish
families who were fleeing the Nazis
Gentiles who helped Jewish families who
were fleeing the Nazis that's not
something that takes muscular action in
the moment but if you're busted you know
if you're if you know if you're a Dutch
farmer and you have a you know Jewish
Family in your Bas basement you're dead
yeah you're
executed women were more considerably
more likely to make that decision than
men were and so what happens is that if
you have a say a group of coal miners
who are stuck in a coal mine for a week
um the first group of sort of
spontaneous the first kind of
spontaneous leaders you get are the
classically male sort of action-oriented
grab a pickaxe and start digging when
those efforts fail another kind of
leader takes over they're way more
empathic they're way more um affiliative
they reach negotiated solutions they
make people feel they try to make people
feel good they're in the classically
female role and what's so interesting
about that is that the male and female
roles will be filled regardless of the
sex so a group of women with no men
around a woman will jump in will jump
onto the railroad tracks and to save the
kid right if there are no men around if
there are no women around a man will
step forward and act in that wonderfully
moral empathic way that women are known
for and so Society sort of needs both of
these gender roles and it doesn't really
care if an actual man or an actual woman
fills
them so this uh this we don't have to
cover this one at length but I also
found it fascinating to read about the
iroy peacetime leaders versus war time
leaders right and and how they switched
between the two and how they were so
clearly uh delineated right I mean when
circumstances changed it's like okay
like it's almost like a football game
it's like okay offense you're off the
field defense you're in and uh how does
this and and I'm not uh much of a a
policy or politics wonk
but I I struggle with trying to assess
political candidates how do you think of
assessing political candidates
presidential or otherwise when you're
when you have to vote for one person
well it's I mean I it's a very
interesting question the iray sort of
figured it out as he said the in peace
time they had s Saums who were partly
partly elected by women right so I mean
so that so the the female voice what was
found in the selection of ss they ran
peaceful society when War started the
Saums stepped down and War leaders took
over and if the people they were
fighting sued for
peace it was not the war leaders who
considered the deal it was the Saums and
and if peace was accepted the war
leaders stepped down immediately and
it's really interesting because the US
Constitution parts of it are based
on the Law of
Peace and um Thomas Payne did a lot of
work sort of incorporating the Natural
Rights of Man as were exemplified by iro
Society um into the intellectual basis
for American
governance um but as soon as the British
surrendered George Washington was
basically the supreme leader he was the
military leader in the colonies was when
they were fighting the British and as
soon as the British surrendered he
formerly gave up power gave up control
to the civilian government um it was a
very very important thing to do because
otherwise he could have continued on as
quote King and that would not be a
democracy and and my guess is that they
took that he took that idea from the
iry military thinking and peace thinking
are very very they very require very
different sensibilities very different
um calculations of cost and benefit um
and so there there is the the conundrum
for us right now is we elect a president
who in time of war is also a the
military
leader and I think in a democracy the
idea that you have a non-military person
at the top of the chain of command is
very very sensible you do not want a
society run by the military that's a
military dictatorship we do not want
that but it does call for very um conf
maybe even conflicting traits in a
single person you know the wisdom and
the gentleness of a peacetime leader the
empathy of a peacetime leader and the um
capacity for
violence and Effectiveness and
decisiveness in a wartime leader you're
asking an almost schizophr you're asking
someone to be almost schizophrenic if
they can do both of those well yeah
equally
well uh see so you mentioned a couple of
historical figures uh why did Ben
Franklin complained that settlers along
the frontier were constantly absconding
to live with the Indians but that the
opposite almost never happened why why
is that well it was this sort of strange
phenomena right the I mean the Christian
Society settled the Eastern Seaboard of
the new world uh in the 1600s
1700s and Beyond the you know sort of
beyond the tree line were the Savages
right they weren't Christian they
weren't civilized they went about they
ran about almost naked and they hunted
wild animals and fornicated and
everything else right I mean it's sort
of Satan Satan's Den right sounds pretty
fun sounds pretty great right maybe
that's just
me so for the Christian sort of s
civilized Christian Society of that era
um they clearly felt that they were the
superior Godly society and but what
happened was that superiority that qu
very quality of civilization and
Christianity was also quite stifling
right we didn't evolve to live I mean we
didn't evolve evolve as as the Human
animals that we are social animals that
we are um to live in within the
strictures of of sort of puran society
and so young men particularly but young
women as well were constantly the
frontier was constantly sort of bleeding
young people who went off drifted off to
live with the Indians I I mean the
movement that the sort of societal
movement was I mean it was a trickle but
it was significant constantly towards
the tribes and not and the Indians were
never running off to join White Society
right and then there were even weirder
cases this is you're talking about the
people who were kidnapped that was the
part that surprised me the most I was
like okay I can kind of see the appeal
of being off in the woods free of
certain constraints and fornicating that
sounds that that's probably a pretty
appealing Daydream to like a Pon you
know farmer you know youngest son is
but the the number of people who were
kidnapped taken as supposedly slaves who
then refused or very
unwillingly uh refused to come back to
White Society or or very unwillingly
came I mean it's just well my book
tribes starts with this story of
pontiac's rebellion and and in the in
Western Pennsylvania Eastern Ohio and
Chief Pontiac fought the um Colonial
powers for years very effectively but
eventually they sued for peace and one
of the deals was part of the deal the
main part of the deal was that he give
up 200 and some white captives that have
been taken from the uh from the
Frontiers and um a significant number of
the captives did not want to be returned
to their home to their homes to their
society and they actually weren't slaves
and what's interesting about I mean the
people thought that that's what happened
to them in fact what happened to them is
that the the captives who weren't killed
and some were killed out of Revenge for
losses that the Indians had taken on on
the battlefield but the ones who weren't
killed were adopted and as soon as you
were adopted you were considered
absolutely one of the tribe there was no
distinction whatsoever you were given to
a family that had lost someone on the
battlefield and you were the replacement
for that person's son or daughter and
these
people I mean there were two young women
who were repatriated because of this
peace Accord after pontiac's rebellion
and and two young
women actually managed to escape and
make their way back to their adopted
families and this happened over and over
and over again um all the way as the
frontier marched Across America there
were constantly these stories of people
who were taken by the Indians and didn't
want to come home and and the reason
that was given was that it was an
egalitarian
society it was not stratified by class
by income by inherited wealth by
inherited power
everyone was equal there were leaders
but there were leaders who were followed
voluntarily and if you didn't like the
leadership style of Chief Pontiac well
you know you could you could just take
your family and move up mosan creek and
move in with your wife's cousin's family
with this other group and so Authority
was all um Authority was never imposed
Authority was accepted and that led to a
really basic equality in in native
societies and and I should say as an
anthropologist the sort of
homonid groups that we evolved from that
we were for hundreds of thousands of
years all of the evidence that
anthropologists archaeologists have been
able to assemble is that they were
extremely egalitarian groups there I
mean partly you can't carry much wealth
right if you're a mobile nomadic Society
how much wealth can you really carry and
it really keep in a society that lives
in groups of 40 or 50 that is mobile
it's extremely hard to accumulate
differences of of wealth and therefore
status how does that relate
to your experiences in war and
interviewing people who have been
subjected to war not necessarily as
soldiers uh I mean you mentioned the
Blitz and so on but how does this relate
to to those experiences well one of the
many ironies of war is that it's Savage
and it's violent and it's completely
anti-human but it prod produces an
intensity of human connection that you
really can't you're hard pressed to find
in peace time um so during the Blitz and
I looked a lot at the Blitz in London
and 30,000 people were killed by German
bombs in around 6 months in in and
around
London um the society it didn't collapse
but it contracted sort of in into itself
people were sleeping
shoulder-to-shoulder with complete
strangers in the tube stations um fire
brigades were rushing around trying to
put out fires after the bombing raids um
it was a brutal time and the government
was prepared for Mass psychiatric
casualties forget about the physical
casualties Mass psychiatric casualties
and but what happened was admissions to
psychiatric
Wards actually went down from pre-war
levels during the bombings and then went
back up after the bombings stopped one
guy said one official said you know it's
amazing we have neurotics driving
ambulances what it seems to be is that
the the the
communal life that is
often forced upon people by hardship by
danger um by Calamity that communal life
is so psychologically beneficial to
people that there's a net gain in
psychological well-being so what you
find is that in countries at War Emil
durkheim the F the the famous
sociologist found that in European
countries that were at war in the
1800s um the suicide rate immediately
went down the murder rate went down all
that kind of antisocial Behavior was
mitigated by the sort of monumental task
that that country was engaged in in New
York I live in New York City in New York
after 9/11 um a massively traumatized
population right and you would think a
lot of um psychological would come out
because of the psychological trauma that
the entire city experienced after 911
that's not what happened the suicide
rate went down after
9/11 um the uh the violent crime rate
went down even Vietnam Vets who were
struggling with PTSD in New York City
said that their symptoms improved after
9/11 because they were needed they had
this sense like oh my God there's a
crisis I'm needed I don't have I I time
time to stop thinking about myself time
to think about the group about us and
that feeling of us is what it not only
does it make people feel good but it
buffers many people from their
psychological demons and it's kind of a
relief so the the one of the recurring
themes that you write about and also
that we spoke about where uh after your
Ted Talk from a few years ago with some
of the feedback from vets uh from
different Wars was that they they missed
the war and from civilians as well in
this book it's like there there are
certain aspects
of the war time maybe a perceived
greater level of humanity even oddly
enough that was lost once uh once peace
was uh regained or
achieved uh how do
you how can one potentially go
about and this is sort of multiple
choice question like
manufacturing
catastrophe in a if that makes any sense
like simulating the characteristics that
drive that increased cohesion
Community uh or sense of mental
wellbeing U or just
increase cohesion uh in a way that you
think we've evolved to find very healthy
or healthful because we were discussing
for instance boxing and I had the same
experience in Jiu-Jitsu even though I
know it's terrible for me I mean I get
injured every time I try to do this for
any period of time it's not good for
your physical health uh I mean if you if
you count all of the sort of collateral
damage but one of the appeals was and we
were both talking about the shared
experience of it being complet like
completely egalitarian it's like oh
that's the guy who's really good at
armur or that's the guy who's really
good at stiff jab or that's the guy
whose footwork is really good it's like
you don't half the time don't even know
what they do May don't even know
necessarily their real name I remember
at you know when I was training at this
place called AKA in San Jose it was like
everybody was given some insulting
nickname I mean and looking back on it
it's like wow that actually sounds a lot
like and I've never been in the military
but it kind of makes me think of Full
Metal Jacket and like snowball and you
and so on uh but how how can
someone simulate that or what can we
what can we do focusing for now on like
the the personal wellbeing do you have
any thoughts on on how we might try to
improve things that was a long
question I think you get the idea
um yeah I mean the nickname thing is
really interesting groups of men give
each other nicknames women as far as I
know don't uh it's a really interesting
thing and I think it's a signal of
tribal affiliation of group
affiliation um the male group in our
evolutionary past was extremely
important in hunting and in defense and
the more cohesive and internally
committed all the males were to the
group to everyone else the more
effective they would be at fighting and
at um and at hunting and that and the
survival of the
community depended on them doing that
job as well as on the women doing other
things but it depended on that and
cohesion cohesion is increased among
other things by by um by hardship by
nicknames I mean all by humor I mean all
these things that you see men in groups
do I mean any construction crew in New
York City you walk past them and half
the time they're doubled over laughing I
mean you know like one of the things men
do in groups is make each other laugh
and they give each other nickname so
it's a it's a really really ancient that
what you experience is a very common
thing and I think quite ancient and
serves a real purpose um we we evolved
as a species in in a sort
of in a in
a um experience of sort of ongoing
moderate crisis I mean we're hunter
gatherers we evolved in a pretty harsh
environment um and we've survived in the
harshest of environments in the Arctic
and the Kalahari Desert
um for example and so normal life for
most of human history was a moderate
ongoing
crisis what's very fortunate and
beautiful and wonderful and also in a
weird way tragic about modern society is
that t that crisis has been removed when
you reintroduce a crisis like in the
Blitz in
London um or an earthquake that I wrote
about in avidano Italy early in the in
the 20th century um in avidano something
like 95% of the population was killed
something like that I mean just horrific
I I'm going from memory but unbelievable
casualties there like a nuclear strike
and one of the survivors said that that
what happened afterwards because people
had to rely on each other and so upper
class people lower class people you know
peasants and nobility whatever everyone
sort of crouched around the same
campfires right and what this guy said
was the earth I'll try to do it by
memory I'm almost got it the
earthquake gave us what thew La
promises but does not in fact deliver
which is the equality of all
men I think one of the things that
people like about crisis is that
suddenly everybody's equal and you're
evaluated like in a boxing gym you're
evaluated for your actual conduct in the
moment not for who your father was not
for the clothing that you're wearing you
could go the boxing gym that I work out
at you could be a suit from Midtown you
know with a fancy job in a big bank or
you could be like a really tough poor
kid from the bows of Brooklyn and you're
not judged there's no bias in either
direction there's no bias against the
dude in the suit and there's no bias
against the ghetto kid you know I mean
you're judged for how you act within
that almost Sacred Space of the
gym and what happens in a crisis in a in
a war or an earthquake or whatever is
that people suddenly are judged for how
they act and that is I think one of the
things that the what we're called the
White Indians the the white captives of
the American Indians um I think that is
one of the things that appealed to them
they were no longer in this incredibly
stratified and frankly unfair soci
colonial society they were in a place
where they were they're totally
self-determining in terms of how they
were
staying let's talk about the the sea
train uh and your return to New York
City and I and I'm I'm I'm missing I'm
trying to recall from memory the timing
on this but it leads into a conversation
of PTSD can you take us through that
story yeah um one of the topics of this
book is PTSD post-traumatic stress
disorder um I had this idea because of
my work on the Navajo reservation that
the huge rates of PTSD that we're
experiencing in America right now are
maybe anomalous and then if you live in
a tribal Society the rates would might
be quite low so that was the sort of
Genesis of my book so I talked about my
own experience with
PTSD I've been a war reporter since the
early 990s I stopped after one of my
best friends was killed in combat a few
years ago but the first really traumatic
assignment that I had was in Northern
Afghanistan a year before
911 in the fall of 2000 I was with Ahmed
sha masud who was the leader of the
Northern Alliance and he he was fighting
the Taliban he was completely
outnumbered outgunned you know back then
the Taliban had fighter planes the
Taliban had tanks they had artillery
they had all the toys right and masud
his forces were the sort of gorillas
well it's great to be with the gorillas
until you start getting shelled right
and or bombed or whatever and um so we
had a tough we I was up there for two
months and we saw and went through some
very tough things and I got back to New
York young man you well your your age
late 30s and
uh I I just felt complet like that
nothing would ever affect me right I
just assumed it complete invulnerability
to
everything and I got back to New York
and um a little shaken up but all right
and then one day I went down into the
subway and that's something I did every
day and it was rush hour there were a
lot of people and I was seized with this
incredible panic
attack I'd never had one in my
life everything I was looking at seemed
like a mortal threat intellectually I
knew it wasn't but it felt like it was
and I was way more scared than I'd ever
been in Afghanistan i' had been plenty
scared in
Afghanistan the trains were going too
fast and they were going to jump the
tracks and leap up onto the platform and
kill me the crowds were suddenly going
to turn on me and beat me to death the
lights were too bright the lights were
going to somehow going to kill me it was
too loud the noise was going to
everything was a mortal threat and I
backed up against the iron support
column and just sort of waited for it
and I then I finally sprinted out of
there and took a taxi and that kept
happening anytime I was in a small like
an enclosed place with too many people
too much going on I would just
panic I just thought I was going crazy I
had no idea that it was in any way
connected to the combat that I'd been in
until a couple of years later I was
talking to a woman who was a
psychologist it was a friend of a friend
I was at a um picnic actually and she
asked about my War reporting and if I
had any suffered any consequence
consequences from it I was like no of
course not I'm fine and for some reason
I thought to sort of mention but once in
a while I have a weird panic
attack and she nodded in that way the
trinks stew yeah hm interesting you know
and she said
well and it was the and it was the
spring of
2003 and she nodded and she said well
that's interesting she said that's
called
PTSD and you know we just invaded Iraq
right and she said you're going to be
hearing quite a bit about that in the
coming years as indeed we
have and why are the rates is are the
rates of PTSD in the US anomalous are
they unusually high compared to other
other uh other cultures or other
countries and if so why is
that well the truth about PTSD is that
if you almost 100% of people who have
been
traumatized either seen something
gruesome or feared for their own life
and I should add that the witnessing of
harm to others is more traumatic than
danger is it's interesting
but almost 100% of people who have been
traumatized get short-term PTSD that's
what I got last some weeks last some
months goes away therapy helps whatever
but you know we're we're we're we're
humans right I mean we're adapted to
survive danger and stress and hardship
and all that all that other stuff we
wouldn't be here right so so trauma if
the trauma was psychologically crippling
to humans humans wouldn't
exist um around 20% of people get
long-term PTSD
so they passed the point where they
should have recovered and they're stuck
in this trauma Loop and they can't get
out of it that's around 20% of
people now you look at the US
military every year
I'm sorry every war the casualty rate
thank God has gone down because the
intensity of the combat has gone down as
bad as World War I was it wasn't as bad
as a Civil War World War II was not as
intense the combat was not as intense
there were not the mass casualties of
World War I Korea Vietnam the war on
terror has the lowest casualty rates of
any War the US has fought major war um
but as the casualty rates have gone down
and the level of trauma has gone down
disability claims have gone up they're
going the wrong
directions right
now about 10% of the US military
actually experiences any combat at all
one out of 10
soldiers um the rest of them are very
are they're crucial they're necessary
they're not getting directly
traumatized but something like 50% of
the US military has filed for some form
of PTSD
disability so there's 40% in there that
are a bit of a mystery right
um they come home and they're deeply
dangerously alienated depressed they
don't fit
in um something's Gravely wrong
and my theory is that what they're
experiencing isn't a reaction to trauma
they couldn't be because most of them
weren't traumatized what they're
experiencing is
the um it's a radical readjust
adjustment from Platoon life a platoon
is 40 or 50 people you're sleeping
depending on what kind of Base you're on
shoulder-to-shoulder in the dirt or cot
to cot in a in a some kind of bungalow
or you know whatever but it's all group
living right you're eating meals
together doing missions and patrols
together you're doing everything
together for over a year that is exactly
how humans evolve to live that is
exactly our
prehistory so that you experience that
incredible tight Co iion with your
platoon now there might be people you
have conflicts with it doesn't mean it's
one big Love Fest but it is close and
it's close with people that you would
that you you know your life depends on
and then suddenly you're sprung from
that and you're back in modern
society and I think what's afflicting a
lot of these vets isn't a response to
trauma it couldn't be it's a response to
the sudden aloneness and loneliness that
that modern
society
um is known for unfortunately and you
also have talked about how for instance
returning peace score volunteers also
suffer from depression right for the I
mean similar maybe not identical but
related reintegration issues yeah I mean
you can see that I mean to the extent
that you know this is proof whatever
it's an interesting example I mean so
you spend two years in you know Cameroon
incredibly incredibly poor country in
Africa central Africa in a really poor
Village I mean that's a tough way to
live for a couple of years for American
who grew up in modern society um and
then after two years you come home and
the depression rate for people coming
back from peace cor service is
astronomical it's something like
50% 25% 50% it's enormous it's it's akin
to soldiers right so so there you have
this common theme you know peace peace
for core volunteers are not traumatized
but they experience like soldiers this
radical transition from from closeness V
lit literally Village Life back to you
know the American suburb or whatever I
mean this is the first Society I mean
modern Western societies the first
Society in human history where people
live alone in an apartment unheard of
children have their own bedrooms they're
locked in a room by themselves at night
it's terrifying to young children I mean
we're primates right baby primates if
they're alone in the jungle are
incredibly vulnerable and you know human
infants know this of course so they
don't want to be put in a room by the M
themselves they know it's in a in an
evolutionary sense they know it's
dangerous and they cry and they scream
was it
90%
contact I might be pulling that out of
my ass but you you talked about the sort
of contact percentages or uh yeah the
skin-on-skin contact for infants um and
young children in tribal societies is as
high as 90% of the time skin on-skin
contact and the study looked at skin
on-skin contact in American society I
think it was in the 70s the study was
done and it was as low as 177% something
like that um now you could say okay well
people have to work they have jobs you
know what I'm all true um but that
doesn't
mean that that radical shift in child
rearing doesn't have
consequences how much of the the so PTSD
is is very interesting to me for a
number of reasons uh one is that I have
quite a few friends now who are either
active military or were active for a
period of time and but most of my
exposure has been to guys in say the
seals or Marine Force Recon and so on
uh I have quite a few questions related
to this but so that's that's part one of
the interest part two of the interest is
that I've been involved
with research and funding research
related to the use of
psychedelics to address uh untreatable
or treatment resistant depression at
places like John's Hopkins and when you
when you dig into that scientific
Community you find a lot of people using
for instance MDMA with vets uh to try to
address PTSD so this has been a a sort
of recurrent topic that that has popped
up for me a couple of questions for you
the first is and the the fact of the
matter is I don't have perfect
transparency into these folks lives nor
should I but the the guys who I've spent
a lot of time with in some of these
Special Operations units do not seem to
exhibit any symptoms of PTSD and I'm
sure that's not true across the board
but do you see a lot of differences in
terms of those types of units
versus
uh I I I don't know the proper
terminology here but just like basic
infantry men or yeah or support units
supp what I mean what it seems to be is
that unit cohesion is a buffer for
psychological um
struggles and including PTSD so the more
highly
trained the soldier the more highly
trained the unit the more
psychologically resilient they are even
though they might be taking higher
casualties yeah and what's so
interesting about trauma is that it it's
not necessarily related to the level of
danger it's related to the level of
control that you feel that you have so
if you're a sort of standard issue
support unit rear
base
Soldier uh you know one of the huge
bases that the American Military has or
the Israeli military has for example in
previous Wars in Israel um maybe the you
know the the random Mort round comes in
right and that is strangely that is C is
more a greater proportion of psychiatric
casualties than Frontline units doing
very intense fighting but they're and
they're taking higher casualties but
they're incredibly well trained so they
have a sense of Mastery over their
environment yeah they also have a very
high degree of uh perceived agency I
would imagine just because they're on
offense right if you're in a Commando
unit you get dropped Behind Enemy Lines
in a black helicopter and you have well
the go command AB absolutely I mean you
know it's game on right the big game
football you know football game or
whatever I mean we're W you know humans
are wired for action and War when need
be and it you know your your neuros
circuitry just lights up and there's all
kinds of hormonal stuff going on I mean
you're you have an enormous agency but
it even is true I read a on my pre
previous book called War um I saw this
study where some Army psych psychiatrist
they like to unluckiest Army
psychiatrist in the whole military
probably at that time were at some for
like some like remote Outpost with
special forces soldiers along like I
don't know up up near the DMZ and and
they were dropped in there and they were
just doing some standard study
psychological assessment of these guys
right and these these guys are real
badasses they were like SF you know like
re the real
deal and so these
psychologists they found out that the
that the base it was a 20-man position
something like that the base was about
to be attacked by a battalion of NVA
like 500 men right and there was 20 guys
there something like that so the
psychologist thought oh perfect this is
a perfect moment to measure stress in
soldiers right so definitely looking at
the Silver Lining that's right yeah
exactly so they started taking cortisol
levels hourly from the
soldiers and the officers the lieutenant
the poor Lieutenant he's probably 22
right his cortisol levels he's not he's
young he's not very well trained and he
has a huge amount of responsibility is
the officer right he's a commanding
officer his cortisol levels are through
the
roof right up into the point where the
attack was supposed to begin because
they had Intel that these guys were
coming right and then after that time
pass his cortisol level steadily
declined and it turned out there was no
attack right and then he went returned
to normal this special forces guys were
the opposite as soon as they heard that
they were about to experience an
overwhelming attack
their cortisol levels dropped they got
super calm and they started doing the
reason their cortisol levels dropped is
because they they it was stressful for
them to wait for the unknown but as soon
as they knew they were going to be
attacked they had a plan of action they
started filling sandbags they started
cleaning their rifles they started
stockpiling their ammo getting the
plasma bags ready whatever they do
before an attack all of that busyness
gave them a sense of Mastery in control
that actually made them feel less
anxious than them just waiting around on
an average day in a dangerous place so
the coming back
to and I I really didn't think about
this until now but when we're talking
about PTSD and and potential causes
right so you have going from a very
unified sort of tribal existence that
we've evolved to be part of to this very
unusual
sort of isolated modern existence you
also have what strikes me at least is
we're looking at the agency versus lack
of
agency the the sense of a clear purpose
and a task right it's like if you get if
the towers get hit at 9911 and there's a
call for blood drives and everybody
standing online of every different race
color or Creed it's like you have a very
clear concrete purpose in front of you
as opposed to what I think a lot of us
experience and I'm not immune to this
certainly there there are like weeks and
months where I'm like what the am I
doing like I really just like don't know
what I should be doing in life but a
crisis or perceived crisis is a forcing
function it's like you have a very clear
directive of some type or another uh
what what do you think are the most and
just to and then a third which could be
is related certainly but might be
independently addressable is when you
come into an isolated existence you're
in an apartment by yourself which quite
frankly I am a lot of the time and I
don't think it's healthy for me is a
focus on me like a focus on I is just a
breeding ground for neurosis and mental
illness I think and I I and when you
take for instance uh certain types of
psychedelics it disrupts the default
mode network has very particular
neurological effects that increase the
sense of uh Oneness and unity with
others so it REM it it in some ways
mitigates that Focus on uh on this on
the uh the first person what can we do
to better support troops U particularly
and this is a question from another
friend who's who's a big fan of your
work but you know he views himself quite
proudly is sort of a bleeding heart
liberal and he he's feels very
conflicted
because he wants to support troops at
the same time he wants to ask well did
you find the wmds right and so he he's
conflicted as to how to the troops
without feeling like he's supporting
senseless Wars how would
you how would you answer that or talk to
that well countries go to war through a
political process that's run by the
government and the troops have nothing
to do with the war in that sense right I
mean like guys who were drilling for oil
in North
Dakota really don't have anything to do
with global warming you know they're
providing something that our society has
decided at once including a lot of
environmentalists frankly are driving
around in cars they're running gasoline
so with bumper stickers that say no
blood for yeah no exactly right so
there's a massive hypocrisy even though
it's well-meaning so but you can't
mistake the soldiers for the war if
you're upset about the wars that the US
gets into you have to address that to
the government the soldiers themselves
have simply volunteered to do anything
think about how profound this is they
have volunteered to do anything that the
nation asked them to do for very very
low amounts of money anything right and
if we told them to plant trees in Canada
they'd go do that and if we told them to
go invade Canada they'd do that they
were like whatever you want we're going
to do so there's no
conflict you're you're there's no
conflict between Pro being disagreeing
with a
war and sort of honoring people who have
said for for $40,000 a year I will do
whatever you think this nation needs
done that's an incredibly honorable
thing
and if you want
to create a sense of a un a sense of
unity of purpose in this country which I
think would be enormously
psychologically beneficial to soldiers I
mean soldiers
experience Unity of purpose in their
platoon then they come back to a country
to this country which is basically a war
with itself I mean we live in racially
divided communities the gap between rich
and poor is bad and growing worse the
political parties
are speak with Incredible contempt for
one another um if you're a soldier and
you fought for this country and you come
back to this mess I mean of course
they're messed up the soldiers I mean of
course they are like what like come on
guys we fought for you and you can't
even get along in peace time I mean you
guys are experiencing peace and you're
not you can't even get along so you want
Unity of purpose in this country one way
to get there is to make as 50 years ago
racist speech was acceptable
socially now it's unacceptable it's
protected under Free
Speech but it's politically and socially
unacceptable contemptuous speech for
your fellow citizens for your political
adversary likewise it's protected under
the First Amendment but it should be um
considered so damaging to the social
Fabric and the interest of this nation
that it's effectively banned from
society by Common
consensus that would that would help
that would help soldiers it would help
all of us national service would be
amazing I think it's morally wrong to
force people to fight a war they don't
want to fight but national service with
a military option where every
18-year-old or every young person had to
do a year or two of national service
would
be I mean that would truly create the
Melting Pot that this country is and
should be the classes the races get
mixed in this very um egalitarian way it
would create a comet like in Israel
which has a PTSD rate by the way of 1%
It would create this sort of common
experience and this and this Unity of
purpose which is so profoundly um
healthful psychologically what would
some of the what might some of the
non-military options look like for that
year or two of service
I mean what do what's the nation need
done you know I mean we need help in the
inner cities you know we need
infrastructure repair I don't know what
I mean it could resemble like a Teach
for America or a uh Peace Corp type of
capacity yeah anything whatever you I
mean I mean for us for us collectively
to use our imagination and we have two
things right we have this incredible
resource of our young
people and we have a nation that's
deeply deeply in
crisis and the the one thing that
unifies us is being attacked right we're
attacked by terrorists and suddenly
we're a unified country and we we don't
want to we don't want to have to wait
for tragedy to unify us right we want to
beat it to the punch and actually unify
our country for positive reasons instead
of as a reaction to a a horrible attack
so I promised I would come back to the
Viking helmet so I want I want to
address the Viking helmet
uh so I mean let me let me try to this
is from memory let me let me try to give
a sketch so you're in Spain correct you
go out to a bar with some of your
buddies and you know what I'll let I'll
let you tell it because I think you'll
do it more justice but it it it
underscores a point that I want to ask
you about so could you could you yeah of
course so and they weren they weren't
even my buddies they became my buddies
so I was I was 22 years old my father
grew up in Spain and in France and I I
grew up going to those countries and
when I was you know after college I just
I I decided I'd read a lot of
Hemingway um I you know this is all
pretty predictable right I read a lot of
Heming way I wanted to go to pona to see
the running of the bolts to see or
participate in the running of the bolts
right so the sun Festival of s s Fermin
In in Pomona is this big Citywide you
know like freak Show basically for a
week and um I was sleeping on someone's
couch and one night I slept on a park
bench I mean it's just a free for- all
it's amazing time right and I went out
to this
bar um in preparation for the running of
the bulls the next morning no one who's
within the barricades where the where
they run the Bulls no
one they fire the cannon off at one at
at 7:00 in the morning to start the
release the Bulls from the arena and
they charge through town through these
barricades and no one who's within those
barricades at 7:00 a.m. woke up at 6:00
a.m. to do it I mean everyone's been up
all anyone who's in that thing has been
up all night well I was going to be one
of them so I go to this some stupid
little bar saw us on the floor I speak I
spoke pretty good Spanish at the time I
immediately started talking to these two
young Spaniards who are
just completely shitfaced right and one
of them has a a leather sort of drinking
bag around I don't know howse to
describe it a leather drinking bag
called a b around his neck which is
filled with red wine and he keeps trying
to get the red wine squirt the red wine
to his mouth but he keeps missing it's
all over his white T-shirt and these
guys are having the best time in the
world and we're we just become friends
instantly we're they're talking and one
of them the drunkest of the two has a
cheap plastic Viking helmet on his head
and I didn't really think about it much
we're talking and um suddenly these
three very tough-looking North African
kids walk in and I had lived in France
for a while with my family when I was
1213 so I spoke French also these three
really tough looking Algerian or
Moroccan kids walking in and they're
tough looking guys right and they walk
into the bar and the biggest of them
walks right up to my new friend I've
known him for maybe half an hour and
grabs the Viking helmet off his hand and
says that's mine you stole
it so I'm the only one who speaks both
languages so now I'm translating right
and my friend my my Spanish friend new
Spanish friend says tries to grab it
back and says no that's mine I don't
know who you are and the Moroccan guys
and the two Spanish guys everyone
suddenly has a hand on the Viking helmet
and they start pulling at it and it's
rapidly devolving into a pretty good bar
fight right and it the the helmet starts
to rip it's just cheap plastic right and
one of them shouts it's sort of King
King Solomon's judgment almost like one
of themselves stop stop we're we're
we're we're ripping it you know and they
stop everyone stops because no one wants
to destroy the thing they're all
fighting over
right
and one of the the two Spanish guys I
think the less drunk of the two turns to
me and says I have an idea will you take
my place at this helmet and will you
defend it I mean this wonderful elegant
way that Spaniards have of speaking
particularly when they're drunk will you
defend it upon the an you know honor of
your ancestors and your good name and
blah blah blah and I'm thinking like how
long do you have to know a guy before
you have to back him up in a bar fight I
mean is it under an hour really is
that's it like and uh so I I say yes
I'll defend the helmet Etc and I take my
place at the helmet and he goes to the
bartender now the whole bar is watching
this this is high theater right at this
point and uh so me and the Spanish kid
are glaring at the Moroccans and they're
glaring back and we're faced off around
this helmet I'm really hoping it doesn't
go to where you know it looks like it's
headed so that the Spanish guy goes to
the bar and has a quick conference with
the bartender who produces a big jug of
cheap Spanish red wine and cracks the
top open and hands it to him and the guy
comes
back and fills the Viking helmet to the
brim with red wine now no one wants to
be the who spills the red wine
right it's this Festival of sun Fermin
the whole thing's running on red wine
like no one wants to spill it right it
just looks bad so he fills the helmet to
the brim brim with red wine and he puts
his hand under it and he says okay now
everyone let go and no one wants to be
the idiot who spills the wine so
everyone lets go and he presents it to
the biggest toughest looking Moroccan
kid and says you're a guest in our
country so you drink
first and the guy drank and he passed it
to his left and then it went NE and it
went around the circle and then when it
was empty of red wine it got filled up
and then eventually they just got
another jug and started passing The Jug
around an hour later I'm talking to like
some girl an hour later like I
eventually extricate myself from this
and I look over and the five of them who
are ready to tear each other to Pieces
right the five of them are hanging off
each other singing in unison in two
different languages and the and the
Viking helmet has been completely
forgotten and is under a table in the
corner so the I underlined this and put
a bunch of stars next to it there are a
lot of underlines in this book for me
what I liked about the encounter was
that it showed how very close the energy
of male conflict and male closeness can
be so I I I want to get your thoughts
and advice on this on something very
closely related which is I I've felt for
a long time and this is completely
unsubstantiated I mean it's just a pet
theory that a lot of the societal issues
that we see are a direct result of male
misbehavior from those who do not have
an outlet for just innate capacity for
violence and force and
I think it's such a great story because
it shows how that can be in some cases
directed right so you're like oh
these guys are about to turn into like
Meatheads pounding each other's brains
out but like with with a little with a
little finesse and enough red wine like
that's all diffused and now they're best
buddies and and uh you and
I I heard a story very much like this
where there's a I'm not going to name
him but this this very kind of
cantankerous outspoken abrasive U
billionaire walked up to this huge
Argentine guy at a party that I was in a
different room uh at the time for and uh
pushed the guy cuz he they were both
drunk and he pushed this huge Argentine
guy because he assumed I'm the
billionaire here I'm the tough guy who's
the alpha male what's this guy going to
do and what the guy did was turn around
picked him up like a professional
wrestler over his head and slammed him
on top of a folding table and shattered
the table
oh that's great so everyone's assuming
holy like this guy's going to get
his life destroyed this this guy's going
to sue the out of him but he
couldn't because of like the the the the
sort of reputational stakes like he it
would be a response that would like
forever shame him if that was the
response cuz he clearly instigated it
and then a half hour later they're best
of friends doing shots together but it
doesn't always end that uh neatly right
and so do you have any thoughts on
how in in the in the society in which we
live let's just say in this case in the
US we can end up with more male
closeness and less sort of male violence
do you have any thoughts on that well
It's Tricky
um I mean how do we have less heart
disease in a society that where people
drive and they have plenty most people
have plenty of food and a lot of fats
and sugars you know I mean I mean the
the very safety of this Society the very
thing that makes us lucky also creat
creates a danger right the diseases of
affluence that's right so the wonderful
thing about the society is that we don't
have to
organize groups of young men and put
weapons in their hands and send them out
to the edge of
town to fight off an
incursion from the young men of an of an
of an enemy town a hostile town we
that's not happening anymore right I
mean Wars are big formal things that for
the United States almost always happen
else where but in terms of our
communities and our society at home we
no longer have to organize young men and
prepare them for group violence so that
we can survive that's been the human
Norm for 2 million years either from
predators or from other humans men young
men function in groups and function
selflessly in groups extremely
well um you can organize 20 30 40 50
young men and give them a task a
dangerous task and they perform not only
do they perform it very very well the
harder the task is the closer they get
um women are used for incredibly
important I mean I'm talking in sort of
human evolution across the span of human
history women are used for equally
important tasks but usually not group
tasks like that it's really the boys
that are told to either hunt or fight in
groups and so they they get very very
good at it and the in modern society
if you what young men want to do is
Achieve Honor by defending the community
I mean it's just wired it's just wired
into the male brain to do that if you
don't give young men a good and useful
group to belong
to they will
create a bad group to belong to but one
way or another they're going to create a
group and they're going to find
something an adversary where they can
demonstrate their prowess and their
Unity that thing that they find is often
the law it's the police it's Society
itself in some ways they turn into
skinwalkers they have no outside enemy
so they create an enemy out of society
they don't want to be doing this is one
of the risks of uh wartime leaders being
all the time leaders that's right and
young young young men like young women
for the most part are well intentioned
and want to do right by the their their
community and their society but if you
have a society which is so safe and
protected and removed from the rest of
the world as we are um in some ways
there's sort of nothing useful for the
young men to do and then in their own
adhawk way they create their own trials
right so they take a lot of risks they
do stupid stuff they jump off of stuff
that's too high to jump off of they
drive too fast they get into fights I've
never done any of that they young men
die at six times the rate of young women
from accidents and from violence and
there's a there's a reason for that
they're white ired to demonstrate their
prowess and and it often gets them
killed so this is this is not really
something that that needs a ton of
commentary because I'm not sure we can
resolve you know Millennia and millions
of years of evolution U but I I I
highlighted this part and we talked
about it before we started recording cuz
I it was surprising yet completely
unsurprising at the same time and this
is uh to read a short section here I
once asked a combat vet if he'd rather
have an enemy in his life or another
close friend he looked at me like I was
crazy oh an enemy 100% he said not even
close I already got a lot of friends he
thought about it a little longer anyway
all my best friends I've gotten into
fights with knock down drag out fights
granted we were always drunk when it
happened but think about that he shook
his head as if he couldn't believe it uh
strange creatures we are absolutely
absolutely uh I want to I want to segue
to a couple of listener questions uh
because there were there were some good
ones this one is from Kip MC uh
MC and I'm going to abbreviate it a
little bit but uh how does he feel about
veterans being victims in society after
they return home and get out General
James Mattis who you should definitely
interview this has actually been
recommended a few times uh gave a speech
in 2014 about post-traumatic growth as
he called it and how those experiences
should be considered a precious
commodity one that cannot be simulated
or taught in a
classroom uh how would you comment on
that I I mean VI
victims the the the the status of
victimhood is not a psychologically
healthy place to be
in and I think our
society takes people who are unfortunate
who have experienced something difficult
and in a kind of misguided attempt to
make the world right again for them they
classify them as
victims now they may call them survivors
and they may call them whatever they
want but but actually the role that's
being as that they're being that the
that the person is being asked to play
is one of a victim victims are taken
care of right so after World War II
which
saw casualties that completely
Eclipse even these terrible Wars of our
current day soldiers came back um they
didn't do multiple deployments they
signed up and they were in the Army
until the war was done some of them were
in for 3 four years straight right and
they came
home
and basically they Society said to these
men and it was almost all men in the in
the in the you know combat units Society
said to these men like all right you're
done fighting now we need you at home
you know it's time to get to work we
have a country to
rebuild and they definitely were not
thought of as victims of the war or of
anything um they were thought of much
like I'm sure the Cheyenne and the
kamanche and the Apache and the Sue and
the kyowa Warriors who came back from
the war path they were thought of as
essential and functioning members of
society now maybe they were missing a
limb or maybe they had some trauma to to
to to process but they were needed back
home in the towns and cities of this
great country just as badly as they were
needed in the Pacific in the fields of
Europe and um the the the problem with
victimhood is that
it perpetuates the psychological state
of
passivity and Trauma that you want the
person to escape from right it's I mean
it's the sort of perceived lack of
agency that helped produce the PTSD in
the first
place exactly and you think about what
the the official London official said
about the plitz now we have neurotics
driving ambulances and and also I mean
one thing you wrote about which was U
the presence of of fraud of of course
within disability claims and how uh some
vets who really suffer from severe PTSD
don't want to go to these meetings
because they're afraid they're going to
beat the living out of some guy
who's clearly just doing it to receive a
check or some type of payment yeah you
know it's a very politically delicate
thing to bring up but and and all all
I'm doing is repeating the accounts of
of soldiers and
Veterans um I mean the best thing a
journalist can do is convey information
and that's what I'm doing they they um I
mean their veterans I've talked to who
said they just they won't they won't go
to these group therapy sessions because
you know one out of 20 is some guy who
really didn't see any combat and is
trying to milk the system and pretending
to have
trauma pretending to have pts and he
really doesn't you know one of the
tricky things the VA in trying to speed
up the massive bureaucracy that they
created over the last decades and tried
to speed that up speed up uh disability
claims they said to soldiers if if you
self diagnose think about this if you
self diagnose with PTSD you do not have
to give us proof that anything traumatic
happened you do not have to describe the
incident that you were traumatized in
you just have to tell tell us that you
believe that you were traumatized and
that you had PTSD and that's enough for
a disability check so humans being what
they are some number of people are going
to take advantage of that and and we're
a wealthy country we can easily absorb
those costs so I have zero opinion about
whether we should inquire further but I
should say
that the data show that
having um that having that kind of
dishonesty in a process is actually
psychologically detrimental not only to
the to those specific people who are
being being dishonest but to everybody
it's actually quite
corrosive how many photographs have you
taken on your uh wartime dep uh
deployment is probably not the right
word but
assignments uh you know I I've I carry a
video camera and I shoot a lot of
footage but I've never taken still
photos Okay so with the video footage
that you've shot and by the way when I I
haven't told you this when Restrepo was
first shown like very very first shown
in the northern California area I
tracked it down and drove out to see one
of the very first showings oh really I
did thank you and uh I have some
questions about that but what footage
that you captured if if any come to mind
this is related to a question from
Yasmin hayat uh if you had to choose
let's I'm going to substitute here cuz
it was one photo but I'm going to say
one clip of footage that impacted him
the most which one is it and and why
what did he experience while taking in
this case the
video I mean the things that um have
impacted
me I I I didn't
necessarily sh shoot video of uh
sometimes it's at night we can talk
about uh I would say feel free to to to
answer that
yeah
um when I was in Northern Afghanistan in
there was a big nighttime battle going
on and there was a massed infantry
assault um against entrenched Taliban
positions through Minefield most of the
Northern Alliance s World War One you
know sort of World War I style and um it
was at night and we were right behind
the front lines and a a wave of soldiers
went sort of took the wrong route and
went through this Minefield and a lot of
them got messed up and they were pulled
out of there and we saw them immediately
afterwards they'd sort of been piled
onto the back of a flatbed pickup truck
they're alive you know they had lost
legs and you know traumatic amputations
I mean they were extremely messed up
they're alive most of them probably
survive they're anti-personnel
Minds um and we so we were there where
they were when they were brought into
this sort of forward field Hospital tent
that was lit with kerosene lanterns
right and this is you know this is rough
this is World War I era medine yeah and
um and in the very bright light of these
s propane lanterns kerosene lanterns um
they brought these poor guys in and you
know there was you know 12 guys you know
where their bodies ended at their knee
their bodies ended at their hips you
know I mean they were just I mean it
just you know you don't
realize I mean it's ex it's
psychologically incredibly
deranging to see the human body
rearranged and I found later in my
research that one of the the most
traumatizing things
in terms of PTSD is to see dismemberment
to see the coherence of the human form
rearranged in an odd way that you've
never seen before and it's just it
really tweaks people and I I
um I had a moment of Crisis I mean I I I
went a little crazy it felt like I went
a little crazy I I just
my brain just sort of stopped
functioning
and uh I
I don't even have very clear memories of
it but I I left the tent I couldn't take
it I could not look I could not bear to
see what I was seeing and I left the
tent and I went outside into the cold
Afghan night and lit a cigarette and I
thought you know war is exciting and
it's dramatic and it's important and
it's meaningful and it's all this other
stuff but if you're not also prepared
to look unblinkingly unflinchingly at
the worst aspects of
War uh dismembered people you you really
have no business covering the the quote
good parts and by good I mean the parts
that are aren't
traumatic um if you can't face what's in
that tent you have to get out of the
business
completely and you can't be selective
about your experience of war and but you
have a job to do is to communicate to
your readers back in the United States
everything about what war looks like
including that so grab your damn
notebook and grab your pen and walk in
there and just write down what it is
like to behold such a thing and um as
soon as I this is interesting right as
soon as I had a purpose I was okay my my
self-given purpose was document this
thing that you can you can barely bear
to look at but as soon as I had a job to
do and I'm sure that's how the Medics
dealt with it too as soon as I had a job
to do I was okay and um I wrote it all
down and it was one of the most powerful
parts of this piece that I wrote and I
sort of P you know I passed through the
Gateway through the threshold and I at
that moment I became I've been in plenty
of Wars till then but in that moment I
became a war
reporter
so you mentioned uh not by name but Tim
earlier yeah can you tell us who he was
what happened and how it Ed you yeah Tim
heatherington uh was a wonderful
brilliant uh English photographer who I
was lucky enough to work with on my
project in the coronal Valley I wanted
to document the experience of one
platoon 30 40 50 men throughout one
deployment and I wound up at a little
Outpost called Restrepo and on my second
trip in there I that's when I started
shooting video and thinking about movies
and on my second trip in there I started
working with Tim he was was assigned to
me by Vanity Fair magazine and he
quickly realized that this film project
that I had was a pretty good idea and we
became partners and we went through a
very intense
amazing difficult year together out
there in the coral Valley and we both
got hurt um we both came very close to
getting killed out there we was
extraordinary experience and we became
Brothers
really and we made a film called
Restrepo and it and won a lot of awards
and then it was nominated for an Oscar
and we went off to Los Angeles and this
amazing world of you know Los Angeles
during the Oscars and I I was I was
married at the time and he had you know
he had a girlfriend and we were all out
there together it was incredible
experience we didn't win it didn't
really matter and we had an assignment
to the Arab Spring was exploding all
around us during the Oscars right and so
we had an assignment to go back overseas
and document the Civil War in Libya from
V it fair at the last moment I could
after the Oscars we all went home and we
were going to head to Libya and the last
moment I couldn't go for personal
reasons and Tim went on his own and he
was killed on April 20 in the city of
Mada in Libya um by a mortar round 81mm
mortar that was fired by qaddafi's
forces outside Mada and he bled out in
the back of a rebel pickup truck racing
for the Mada hospital and um I got the
phone you know I got the awful phone
call in in New York
City and um very very quickly uh decided
I would never cover more again um it
wasn't that I was scared of getting
killed that's a fear that you have to
confront early on and I'd sort of
resolved my feelings about it um it's
that in was in watching the news of his
death and he was beloved by people
including my wife danela I just loved
him I mean he just everyone one loved
them and I watched the news of his death
Ripple Ripple outwards from my apartment
cuz I got the news first from my
apartment outward through all the people
that he knew that he loved on out into
people that he didn't even know who
loved them on out through his country
and my country and and I I just
thought I don't want to risk doing that
to the people I love I mean I'm dead
right uh my problems are over but I'm
giving them a lifetime of pain and
sorrow and that's not an honorable thing
to do and so I I got out of the
business what was that what uh was the
date on that again April 20 April 20 yep
um coincidentally the anniversary of
Coline uh Hitler's
birthday there's all kinds of awful
things that happened on April 20 for
some
reason what do you think you your
writing future will look
like tribe is a really different book
from my other books um it's an inquiry
into
something um it's not a story it doesn't
take place on a fishing boat or in an
outpost um it's a meditation and an
inquiry uh about a societ my Society my
country that I love very much and
something feels very very wrong in our
country right now and I think if you
look at the
political political discourse right now
in this country it is completely toxic
and actually more dangerous to our
nation than Isis is I mean really in
real terms of how do we keep this
country together for the next 250 years
Isis is not going to be able to prevent
us from doing that I'm sorry but we
ourselves can and and it's happening
right now and and my book is partly an
attempt to to make people think about
what it means to belong to a group and
this country is a
group so viewing ourselves that way uh
this relates to a question from Bobby
Richards uh working so closely with
service members and vets what would be
the one thing he would recommend that an
American civilian could do for our
vets uh not necessarily as a country but
as
individuals the the main thing that I
can think of is drawn from some of my
research into American Indian Ceremonies
for returning Warriors in the 17th 18th
centuries or vets from the current Wars
19th centuries or vets from the current
Wars um Bas one of the common themes in
these ceremonies is that the warrior
gets to recount in front of his
community what he did for
them on the battlefield and you know
often it's a heroic sort of boasting of
How brave he was and how he killed the
enemy and how you know whatever but it's
this
cathartic um description of A Warrior's
a warrior discharging his duties for his
community and there's something about
doing that for the people you did it
for that seems to be um very very
psychologically healthy to put it in
modern terms because it's a it's almost
a veral in these ceremonies and so I had
the idea I mean we're not going to go
back to a tribal Society I me we can't
we can't you're not you know you'd have
to get rid of the car you know you
whatever we have it's not happening but
we might be able to take certain
structures of tribal life and
incorporate them into modern society
right so we get the best of both worlds
and the way to do that in terms of
returning veterans is to turn the town
hall or the city hall in every community
in this country on Veterans Day into an
open forum for veterans
um so this I have this idea veteran Town
Halls where in my website sebastiany
younger.com there's a page devoted to
this um you open up the town hall and a
veteran from veterans from any War have
the right to stand up and speak for 10
minutes to their
community and I know veterans right some
of them are going to be incredibly proud
of their service and and they're going
to say they the war and it's going to
make liberals
uncomfortable and some of them are just
to just to be clear you would you would
consider yourself a liberal oh I'm
totally liberal yeah yeah but as a
journalist I'm neutral I mean it's
really important as a private person I'm
liberal but as a journalist I really try
to be completely neutral in my
analysis and my evaluation of things
um it conservatives will be made
uncomfortable by veterans standing up
and being incredibly angry about the war
that they had to fight and everyone's
going to be uncomfortable when someone
stands up and just starts crying and
can't even talk cuz they're crying too
hard but all of that is war right we
sent these
people to do a job for us that we deem
necessary collectively deemed necessary
and the emotional Fallout for it um is
okay as long as we process it all
collectively it's not okay if we just
make them deal with it it's not their
War it's our war so all of us need to
deal with it much like the American
Indian tribe did in these ceremonies an
amazing amazing thing so we did this
once in Marblehead
Massachusetts and uh Seth Molton is a
democratic representative from from
Massachusetts who was a Marine
lieutenant in raditi I believe it was
saw some very very tough fighting um he
helped me organize it we did it together
and last Veterans Day in the town of
Marblehead Massachusettes if you were a
civilian and you like to say I support
the troops what that literally meant on
that day last year in Marblehead
Massachusetts was that you really then
should go down to the town hall and
listen to what the veterans had to say
about war was like for them there's no
Q&A there's no debate this is not an
evaluation of the war it's not a
patriotic thing it's not an anti-war
thing it's just this is what the
experience was like and I really really
think that if we could do this in every
country around in every town across the
country that it would be enormously
therapeutic for veterans but even more
important in some ways it would start to
bind the country together again I think
the veterans are suffering because the
country is suffering and if we can heal
ourselves as a
nation the veterans are going to be
fine could not agree more
uh well let's uh let's shift gears just
to my perhaps somewhat typical uh series
of Rapid Fire questions and then we'll
we'll wrap up and have some more coffee
oh and I didn't look at those in advance
so now I'm in trouble all right all
right I'm ready let me get ready here we
go all right I'll let you you limber up
okay I'm doing a little Shadow Boxing
all right the uh so the first is uh when
you hear the word successful who's the
first person who comes to mind and why
Martin Luther King why because he
transformed Society an incredibly
courageous way how do you define courage
or bravery courage is risking or
sacrificing your life for others
what is the book or books that you have
given to others most often as a
gift at playing the fields of the Lord
by Peter
mat I also recently read sapiens by a
guy named Harari which is just
phenomenal I'm going to give that thing
over and over again to everyone I know
there's a friend of mine who's also been
on the podcast named nval ravikant who
you have to meet at some point you guys
would get along famously also one of his
favorites of the last couple years at
play in the fields of the Lord it's a
novel by Peter mat it takes place in the
jungles of of um of South America and
it's about a a sue Indian named Lewis
Moon who grew up on a reservation in the
1970s and he goes down to Brazil to meet
his what he considers his forbears and
it doesn't go very
well that sounds and now am I getting
this right mat also wrote In Search of
the snow leopard or am I getting that
that's right yeah yeah yeah yeah uh
fantastic writer
uh what are you what would your close
friends say you're exceptionally good
at if I had two drinks in each of
them um I think they would say that I'm
really good at not reacting to things
and seeming
like um I'm
unaffected when actually I'm deeply
affected but on the surface you're not
emotionally reactive that's right
sounds like sounds like you're
definitely a closet
stoic uh this is actually not one of my
typical questions but I'm going to throw
this one this is from uh I think it's
Robbie fry it's looks like a very Dutch
name but if you could if you could
combine three different writers into one
super saion that's a Dragon Ball Z
reference don't worry about that um if
you could combine three different
writers into one writer right to like
create the ultimate writer for you who
would May B I think I would have to pick
Cormac
McCarthy Peter
mat and Joan
didan good choices
all uh let's see here where were you so
your
first book commercial book success uh
The Perfect Storm how old were you when
that came out I was uh 35 years old okay
so when the book hit before it was made
into a movie what advice would you give
to your you now what advice would you
give to yourself at that point in
time the the movie part of it didn't
what didn't affect me very much um but
the the sudden attention public
attention that I got when the book
became a bestseller affected me
enormously and I think I would say to my
and I was very anxious about all that I
think I would say to
myself you know there's nothing
the public is not a threat like the
public is actually waiting to hear
someone anything say something that's
helpful and makes sense cuz we're all
trying to get through this life together
and everyone everyone wants some
guidance and if there's anything I can
say through my work or just on a stage
that that that that gives some comfort
or guidance to people they're enormously
receptive and when you when you realize
that we all need each other and we can
all learn from each other your stage
fright goes away and I had a terrific
case of stage fright when my book came
out how do you feel now when you're
getting ready for a talk like your Ted
Talk oh I don't think twice about it I
mean I'm just I I mean it just doesn't
affect me at all I think my heart rate
goes up a little
bit uh what is the most uh what purchase
of $100 or less and we don't have to
stick to that exactly but
recent purchase that has most positively
impacted your life I think sapiens
sapiens yeah I mean that book it's it's
a fun book to read it's amazing I mean I
I just started looking at everything
differently like I mean I love that book
and um but books are I
mean a book is a kind of thing of magic
right I mean it contain it I mean it it
contains a universe of information so
and it's cheap at the price so I that
maybe it's unfair to use a book um $100
or less
um I I mean I think one of the best
values you can buy for a100 you can get
for $100 is an axe a good axe good axe
you can do almost anything with a good
axe any particular type of Axe what are
the characteristics of a good axe
um it's got to be it can't be cheap wood
in the halfs it's got to
be good steel I mean I you know I don't
even know how to evaluate this basically
the more you pay for an axe the better
quality it is and the longer it last and
the better we'll cut and you keep it
really really sharp and you can cut not
as fast as a chainsaw I've used chainsa
a lot in my life but you can
um you can basically do anything with it
given a little bit of time and I've
spent a lot of time in the woods and if
I had to take pick one thing to take
into the woods with me it would be an
axe I was just thinking like how would
you open a tunic can with an axe like
you that's so easy man definitely open
it oh yeah yeah know I remember when I
was a young man my my 20s and I was
living just stupidly in some stupid
apartment in Somerville Massachusetts
and I had a date with this girl this
beautiful girl and I invited her over
and I was going to make spaghetti I mean
I'm like 23 right I'm going to make
spaghetti and I like an idiot I I mean I
got like and I had cans of tomato sauce
and pasta right and she came over and I
realized I didn't have a can open her
and um but I knew the answer and I went
into my room and I got a hatchet that I
had and I opened the T cans of tomato
sauce with a hatchet and I hit it pretty
hard and completely splattered her with
tomato sauce and here's the amazing part
she still went out with
me very memorable at the very least yeah
yeah so then he pulled out a hatchet
that's right yeah exactly right she
probably still reliev that you weren't a
serial killer was going to take your
head off that's right oh my God
uh let's see uh what is something you
believe
even though you can't prove
it wow that's a great
question I believe I'm a good person
what are some of the habits or common
practices of journalists that you
dislike oh God I
I um I really dislike laziness and if
you and if you read a phrase or a
sentence that's familiar I mean there
are these cliches sort of sort of
linguistic tropes like the mortars
slammed into the
hillside I just don't want to read that
again you know like just say it in
original way or don't say it but you're
wasting everybody's time including your
own if you
write by and rely on these sort of
linguistic tropes I really I really
dislike that and
um also the the the point of Journalism
is the truth it's now I was talking
about this on the phone earlier and you
know maybe you overheard me but it but
it it uh the point of Journalism is the
truth the point of Journalism is not to
improve society and there are things
there are facts there are truths that
actually feel
regressive but it doesn't matter because
the point of Journalism isn't to make
everything better it's to give people
accurate information about how things
are and I think journalists really
confuse those two things Advocates are
what we need for improvement but not
journalists journalists provide
information like doctors provide
information when they look at your the
X-ray of your lungs after you smoke for
10 years yeah you need accurate
forensics that's right yeah that's right
what do you think your 70-year-old self
would give to your current self as
advice I think I would say to myself
that the the world is this continually
unfolding set of possibilities and
opportunities
ities
[Music]
and the tricky thing about life
is on the one hand Having the courage to
enter into things that are
unfamiliar but to
also have the wisdom to like stop
exploring when you found something
that's worth sticking around for and I
mean that's true of a place of a person
of a of of a
vocation um in balancing those two
things the courage of exploring and the
um commitment to staying that if you get
those it's very very hard to get those
two the the the ratio the balance of
those two things right and I think my
70-year-old self would say just really
be careful that you don't air on one
side of the other because you have an
ill-conceived idea of who you
are it's a fine line it's a tough uh
tough tough balance yeah it is a tough
balance find it tough personally yeah I
mean yeah absolutely I mean there's a
lot of unhappy people because they're
struggling to find that balance how do
you what are the symptoms of
knowing that you should pursue a given
project right because you've got Navajo
long-distance running you have the
perfect storm you have uh you quite
quite a bit of terrain that you
cover how do you know I what what for
then and I'll just throw it out there to
uh as an example for me I find writing
so difficult personally and I'm so
plotting and I have to go into isolation
it makes me very mentally unhealthy I
only write a book certainly if it's less
painful to write it than to not write it
like it generally manifests itself as a
lot of insomnia in my case and I'm just
like okay like this idea that's been
pestering me like I just need to get it
out of my head and on the paper or I
won't be able to get to sleep um so that
is or but the insomnia could also be
excitement right like I I'm excited
about the possibilities of something and
I just can't sleep that's usually uh one
of the symptoms that I might have like I
might have a live one like this might be
something I can run with what what what
is it like for
you I you know I think the I've only
written five books one was a one was a
collection of I'm not sure who you're
comparing yourself to well the writers
are writing 20 whatever like I you can
always be insecure right no I've and
I've written you to be James Patterson
you're fine I've really written only
four books one's a collection of of uh
short form journalism so um you know
they're all books that had I not written
them I would have wished that someone
else had so I could read
it um one of the things I loved about
Harari sapiens is I finished it and I
and I just thought thank God someone
wrote that book like the world really
needed it and the books that I
write maybe I'm flattering myself but it
feels to me like the the world needs
this book and I know that sounds
horribly grandiose but I have to say I
it's the feeling I'm looking for when
I'm choosing a topic I I I I I really
don't want to write a book that I'm not
sure the world
needs yeah yeah I mean I think uh if you
look at I mean we're sitting in Silicon
Valley if you look at some of the not
some probably all of the biggest
successes I know personally they were
scratching their own it it was something
they felt needed to exist absolutely
absolutely if you had one billboard
anywhere and could put anything you want
on it what would you put on
it I think I would put the word read
read it's the only I was talking about
this recently with some
people that you know we we we don't live
in small groups anymore and when when we
evolved to live in groups of 30 40 50
people and you could gather 50 people
around and have a communal discussion
about how to live what to do who you are
what you want to be you could do that
right we live in a country of 400
million there's no more gathering around
the campfire to figure out who we are
how we want to live what are our values
we can't do that anymore but we still
need to in some ways in a country as
advanced as ours with nuclear weapons
and everything else is even more
important than when we lived in groups
of 50 I mean it's vital that we have
that conversation and the only real way
I think the only real way to have
collectively have that conversation is
through books it's the only thing that's
cheap enough accessible enough to
everybody that contains enough
information that can be shared and
commonly understood it's the only thing
that we can have a group conversation
even in a group of 400 million people
but if people don't read that will never
happen and so I I I really feel
that books it makes books a kind of
sacred object and sacred in the sense
that our society I don't think will
survive without them um and that to me
is as an atheist one definition of
sacredness is something that Humanity
needs in order to
survive Sebastian this has been so much
fun I I could go on and on those of you
who don't have a visual which is all of
you can't see the many many many pages
I've printed out and highlighted and
sketched out by hand uh
but I'm going to tell people where they
can find you and I'm also going to put
this in the show notes of course for
everyone but is there anything
that just as a parting comment you would
like my listeners
to meditate on consider
do well one of the questions I ask in my
book
is um what who would you die for what
ideas would you die
for
um the answer to those questions for
most of human history would come very
readily to the to any person's mouth you
know any Comanche could tell you
instantly who they would die for and
what they would die for and in modern
society it gets more and more
complicated and when you lose the ready
answer to those ancient human questions
you lose a part of yourself you lose a
part of your identity and I you know I
think what I would ask people is you
know what would you die for what would
you die for and what do you what do you
owe your community and in our case our
community is our country what do you owe
your country other than your taxes what
is there anything else you owe all of us
um I don't there's no right answer or
wrong answer it but it's something that
I think everyone should try to ask
themselves this is a great book folks I
uh I read a lot so I have a high bar I
really enjoyed this book it has a ton of
notes and next time that we hang out
probably in New York City and have some
wine I will bring this with me because I
have 20 30 other questions I'd like to
ask you but for those people who might
reflect back on some of your recent
writing and wonder if this is a book
about war it doesn't strike me that it
is a book about war it's a book about
human nature and what we've evolved to
be and what we are and the circumstances
in which we find ourselves and War just
happens to be a very helpful
circumstance in which we can find some
illumination into those subjects uh but
I really enjoyed this book so I
encourage everybody to check it out and
uh Sebastian thanks so much for taking
the time I really appreciate it it's
been a real pleasure talking with you
thank you and everybody listening as
always you can find links to everything
that we discussed in the show notes uh
and that includes uh Sebastian's website
all of his social and whatnot and all
the various resources that came up and
you can find that at 4hourworkweek decom
/ podcast all spelled out and as always
and until next time thank you for
[Music]
listening hey guys this is Tim again
just a few more things before you take
off number one this is five bullet
Friday do you want to get a short email
from me would you enjoy getting a short
email from me every Friday that provides
a little morsel of fun before the
weekend and five bullet Friday is a very
short email where I share the coolest
things I've found or that I've been
pondering over the week that could
include favorite new albums that I've
discovered could include gizmos and
gadgets and all sorts of weird that
I've somehow dug up in the the world of
the esoteric as I do it could include
favorite articles that I've read and
that I've shared with my close friends
for instance and it's very short it's
just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off for the weekend so
if you want want to receive that check
it out just go to 4hourworkweek domcom
that's 4hourworkweek
docomo in your email and you will get
the very next one and if you sign up I
hope you enjoy
it this episode is brought to you by 99
designs 99 designs is a great partner
for creating and growing your business
it's a One-Stop shop for all of your
graphic design needs whether that's a
logo website business card or anything
else I use 99 designs get book cover
prototypes for the 4-Hour Body which
went on to become a number one New York
Times bestseller I also use them for
banner ads illustrations and other
things with 99 designs designers around
the world compete to create the best
design for you you give feedback and
then pick your favorite you end up happy
or you get your money back it's very
simple you can check out a few of my own
designs and those of yours meaning Tim
feris show listeners at 99designs.com
and right now my listeners you guys will
get a free $99 upgrade on your first
design that's 99 designs.com
check it
out this episode is brought to you by
fresh books fresh books is used by a ton
of the startups that I work with or
advise many of the fastest growing it is
used by almost all of the contractors
that I work with it is the easiest way
online to send invoices get paid track
your time for invoicing track your your
clients so they get to the point of
paying you all that stuff that you can
possibly find and right now you can get
a free month of complete unrestricted
use and you do not need a credit card
for the trial to claim your free month
just go to freshbooks.com
Tim and enter Tim in the how did you
hear about a section you can of course
customize it to fit your brand with your
own logo and color and freshbooks shows
you whether or not for instance a client
has looked at the invoice they can send
late payment reminders to your clients
automatically so you do not have to
think about it or chase face them down
and you can track your hours you can do
all sorts of things there are mobile app
lets you take pictures of your receipts
and freshbooks will organize them for
you later it is a great piece of
software and if you are in a small
business or maybe a fast growing
business that is feeling growing pains
and you need to streamline then this is
a place to look because certainly for me
this has been a headache in the past and
it doesn't have to be a headache for you
so check out freshbooks.com
and try it out and see what you think
and until next time thank you for
[Music]
[Applause]
listening